I mean it's you know it's the creepy
deal
do you get nervous oh I'm really yeah
I'm sure I will be just because I feel
like there's it's not pressure it's just
you really want to represent what you do
then and your genre of music well you
know I'm from the country world and I
feel like Keith and I just wanted want
to do a good job you know I wouldn't ask
you about Kelsey Bell you guys just
haven't gotten the chance to like hang
out with her like one on one but I mean
she's you up to such a great start and
she's so sweet and everybody loves her
and she's nominated for a huge award
tonight I got to hear her do her
rehearsals earlier and I just think and
I think it's so cool that healthy and
Marin are both up for Best New Artist
women of country represents yes yeah
what advice would you give to them as
someone so successful you know you got
us as a woman in the music industry you
just got to bring it you know you got to
work you've got to work three times as
hard as the guy is you know and just
make sure you are willing and they are
Marin right here so I was just asking
Carrie for words of wisdom for the
newcomers
[Music]